Yan welcome to St Louis welcome to Grand
chest tour it's it's great to see you
here again what do you think in general
about State of Affairs in the Chess
World on the top let's speak a little
bit about it let's say ding absence
Magnus doesn't play so many doesn't want
to play he says so many classical events
um I mean there are some changes there
are you know some new trends like what
what what do you think about all this
new players new generation is coming
well Magnus uh you know last
I guess last year or something he's
acting little bit like
lant uh of of Chess yeah so so I would
say we're not expecting uh I I think
some chess fans expecting something
different from him uh but I think he
totally claimed his rule you know to to
his right I mean to to enjoy yeah like
to to chill yeah not
to not to be as competitive as before
but still he's like insanely strong and
I think um if we take like all all free
time controls Ultra G he's I think still
the strongest uh but uh his recent
classical results are still like quite
good but not as impressive as before so
maybe he would like to to work on this a
little bit and you know to get back to
his like uh top rating and top shape uh
speaking of ding uh well as far as I
know he's uh you know feeling not great
uh so probably he has some issues so I I
can like I do is to wish him some speedy
and full full recovery and can wait him
can wait to see him playing again yeah
so some rumors say that it will be
already in W but U yeah we'll
see uh so what else uh okay like uh you
know like always uh someone uh
is suspected to be cheating yeah others
are suspecting him yeah and so on so
yeah pretty pretty routine pretty pretty
routine stuff what about New Generation
let's say and also um their successes
and the fact that some of of the young
guys are playing in the candidates
tournament what you think about Indians
Indians are you know you know like last
year I I expected to you know I expected
let's say OB bistan team to win an
Olympia or to play well in Olympia let's
say in
2024 uh but they uh you know came faster
than I expected yes so it was like well
two years two years earli than I thought
and also Indian Indian teams are very
very strong of course and it's not
surprising that uh you know right
now I guess there there are already like
two two indan players in the
candidates so I would say that Gish or
pranda were expected there one of them
and Gish I thought maybe Bas based on F
the circuit he he would be there but
seems like uh Anish over overcame him
yeah the moment yeah at the moment but
yeah it's obvious that maybe he's
playing a bit too much yeah so at some
point I think last couple of months he
just ran out of
energy and yeah he I think he needs some
some time to recharge uh what was
surprising is that we did like uh U well
of course like
was like a well-known like player with
uh great theoretician worked with a lot
of top GMS yeah uh but yeah I was quite
impressed um when I played against him
in the World Cup uh so to be honest I
expected him to you know to to perform
not as well in Rapid section against me
but yeah well he he just played insanely
strong uh way way better than uh than I
could imagine yes so and uh that's quite
unfortunate uh I think that he was
stopped by abasov but what to do so
anyway he he played so so nice uh in um
in is of man uh well
but you know others others play other
players from India like young guys like
of course gkes and Eric GUI and also I
think sadani in in couple of years uh
they are quite quite strong and uh I
mean they have all uh all you know all
the time in the world basically yeah to
to to work to work at at chess yeah to
to get better yeah so that's
uh clearly you know this happens sooner
or later then okay some young Young Guns
young Lads are coming yeah but uh you
know also our generation like '90s and
90s and early '90s you know also not
so you know not so weak at all still and
and and not too old yes so maybe for for
quite some time we can we hold the
pressure but uh yeah speaking about
yourself let's say where do you place
yourself in all this Stu top you know uh
Chess World and do you think you still
have chances and are you fighting to get
the first uh rating in the world well
actually when I was asked what are your
plans for the match I was uh like
kiddingly foring like all right okay I
don't care about the match I want to get
my
2800s and that's probably uh one of one
of the things you know some innocent
joke I was punished for so I guess I had
like
27 27
99.8 which is not enough and that and
that was it so I I don't know about the
first rating um you know that it would
be difficult to to overcome Magnus maybe
maybe he he he he he does this you know
inste instead of me yes so if he keeps
on playing in open
tournaments uh I guess sooner or later
he would uh you know find himself in you
know Among The
Mortals uh but yeah I would really I
would really love uh to to get some um
um you know uh to get something like 28
plus because of you know especially now
then it's like huge rating
deflation uh because of like okay all
all those all these new Fe Fe the rules
uh I guess pretty much everyone is
losing his rating right now a part of
maybe Fab or hiar buty they are having
like some great great
season so yeah this would be still quite
quite pleasing but I think this is not
the main the main goal so you know if
you play well you get everything you get
raing you get titles here you get you
get wins and if you play not so well and
you get nothing yes the the you know the
goal is the same yeah just to to to
learn to learn chess and to play well
yeah and I wish you to play well in the
tournament so the best of FL for you
thank you for the interview thank
[Music]
you